welcome to bananamores this next comic
is responsible for most of my wrinkles
caused by all the laugh lines
you think i was on the floor yeah
let's do it give it up for missy ladies
and gentlemen
that's here for yes
i'm excited to be here i'm excited uh
i'm excited to be out in general
uh because this pandemic is different
you're forced to be at home and deal
with your family
it's tough it's tough i'm a dad of three
um
and i'm a husband to one allegedly
so that's always good uh have one wife
that's always a good thing let's talk
about these kids though um
i found out you know in this pandemic
you find out who's clean and who's
disgusting
uh kids are nice but they're nasty
uh kids are very nasty i love my babies
i do but i just found out how nasty
they are i found out how this whole
thing started it might have started in
my house
it may have started my house and i don't
know because i was i was like the other
day right
here's a true story i was holding my
daughter i was holding my daughter
and out of nowhere you know her nose
running she she wipes her nose and she
just
grabs my lip just just snot and just
transfers it to my lip immediately i got
she was my baby i dropped it ah
just dropped it it was don't feel bad
guys it was it was it was it was
something soft now
i wouldn't she didn't hit her head or
anything just she got to learn she got
to learn you can't you just can't go
putting snot on people's face
it's not it's not a typical practice
it's not a standard practice of mine
it's a different time though it's a
different age man where you gotta wear
these masks
you gotta know people by the eyebrows
you know he just walked around it's like
dj is that you i know those eyebrows
anyway get over here how you doing boys
good to see you
good man you owe me some money i know
everybody before they ask
get some money for me hey hey let me see
eyebrows i'm gonna identify you okay
cool
see you out in public i want to know who
you are good stuff
it's different time though was it was
once upon a time
where me as a black man going to a bank
wearing a mask was unheard of
now now it's welcome it's a great time
to be a bankroll right now business is
booming he's like where's he at where's
he at
he just ran past you with the mask on
everybody got a mask on everybody
it's an amazing time
uh i i grew up a little different than
most people though
i grew up a little different than most
people uh
my mom my mom had me when she was 13
years old
so it's pretty much the same age when
you really think about it um
i mean weren't too much we were doing
different like i couldn't drink she
couldn't drink
i couldn't go to the club she couldn't
go to club we're really doing the same
thing
um you ever went to the you ever went to
school with your mom
you ever done that that's weird like
attend school with your mother
teacher be like hey dj we're gonna tell
on you if you don't you don't get your
act together it's like
go get my mom she's the next class
we ride the same bus we got a whooping
together one time it was crazy it was
unheard of
never done it you if you've never got a
whip until you got into whooping with
the person who's supposed to be your
hero
we were holding
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this kid's going places you heard me
clap it up
for that incredible set
tata charisse is gonna be your next
favorite comedian
guaranteed
yes thank you so much mitzi
yes yes okay okay you guys can stop
clapping now stop clapping
no sit down nothing keep clapping stand
up stand up keep clapping yeah
no seriously man i really feel the love
i really really do
gosh after the year we had an entire
year shut down
during a pandemic imagine moving
during a pandemic that's what i did
that's right y'all
i moved into a new apartment last year
right before everything hit
i didn't have furniture for a whole year
an entire year but i made the best of my
situation
oh yes i did every time i walked into my
apartment it was an adventure you know
some days i was the black cinderella
i'll run up my steps
bust into my living room like impossible
my neighbors be like shut the hell up
i'm like impossible
i had a lot of space i would jungle
oranges and stuff in the
in the kitchen you know i had a lot of
space
only thing i hated was that air mattress
you ever go to sleep on the air mattress
you wake up ain't no air in it
you wake up on the floor yeah that was
me
you go to the right a little bit the
left come up you go to the left a little
bit the right come up
you try to blow it up in the middle of
the night in your sleep
[Music]
it was tragic i took their air mattress
back to walmart three times to try to
get my money back
they denied me each time i'm like you
know what excuse me miss
what's the weight capacity on this bad
boy
she's like um you just made it
it was crazy i'm like you know what i
can't live like this anymore
i need to make some money so i wanted to
get a little creative and try to you
know get a little coin get a little
money you know
i looked into foot modeling yep
i said you know i'm going to put my feet
on the internet and hope people pay me
that didn't work out too well see here's
the thing my feet
they're like a diamond in the rough you
know they're not ugly but they're not
cute and they got to stay done
okay ladies you know what i'm talking
about those feet those toes always got
to be painted
yep that was me that didn't work out
either
so i'm glad to be back here on this
stage hopefully i can get some funds
going and
buy myself a a couch okay
i have a mattress now by the way yep i
do no more air mattresses no more
floating
no no no because even when you want to
have you know a little company you know
i tried to have a little mail company
get my groove on i was so embarrassed by
that air mattress
he walked in i'm like hold on wait a
minute you know let me still give you
some you know what i mean we're just
gonna be floating a little bit you feel
me
but that's my time y'all thank you mitzi
for having me and thank you thank you
thank you world laugh at your screen
dr sharif you better come back to
bananamores and perform
and uh also potentially be my best
friend
you interested we'll talk this next
comic is responsible for most of my
wrinkles caused by all the laugh lines
you'd think i was on the floor
hello everybody yes uh thank you for
clicking the link thank you for watching
here at home uh congratulations to you
watching this because you know what we
got through a pandemic
yeah we did that it's a lot to deal with
i mean
we we had to learn how to zoom
that was the thing uh my mom had her
first
zoom doctor meeting recently and i sat
in with my mom just to help her out
45 minutes go by we're done we close the
laptop i look to my mom and go mom
what'd you think and she looks at me and
goes who was that guy
adorable just adorable i had a zoom
doctor meeting as well i
went to get an eye exam apparently you
can't do that in person
because you know covered but uh i did it
over zoom
and it was great apparently my new
prescription is
720p 1080p
doctor said he'll get me back to 4k no
time so we'll see
a little skeptical about it but you know
we'll see uh
big shout out to all the students out
there who made it work for a whole year
they
they went through school through zoom i
don't know how you did it
props to you guys uh to the parents
props to you guys but
you know what it's been a tough year
let's save some money don't buy a
yearbook for your student this year
you know what you do go over and
screenshot the zoom class
save that as a pdf and have your student
send it out
to all its friends and they can sign it
digitally and that's it you save 100
bucks so you're welcome that's on the
house free tip
there um yeah quarantine was was
was difficult for everybody for me i got
to do everything i wanted to do and
never got a chance to do like i read
books and i saw movies i cleaned my
belly button
i recommend doing that had sand in there
like when was the last time i went to
the beach
i had a cubic zirconia growing in there
also blue lint it reminded me it's like
what happened
to that blue sweater i like that one
i gotta watch that said again let's
rewind
that comedian knows how to work a crowd
am i right
dan levy and natasha legero are here to
double
team you with friendship and funnies and
that's what i call
jokes you know call me old-fashioned
hello drew barrymore and friends
i'm dan and i'm natasha and we're the
hosts of house hunters comedians on
couches
unfiltered on discovery plus which
actually takes longer to say than it
does to produce an entire season
we actually shot two episodes just while
we were waiting to log on to the zoom
what's crazy though is even though we
made 18 episodes of the show
this is the first time natasha and i
have actually been in the same space and
i got to say natasha
you got shorter oh well dan you somehow
got more jewish
whoa you cannot say that kind of stuff
anymore you have to be woke
at all times i know and i'm very woke
i mean i have a twitter and my husband's
been to a protest
so don't talk to me about woke you're a
millennial look at you
look we are look the point is
we love all things real estate and
before we even had the show
we would just send each other red food
links like all the time i'm in escrow on
three properties right now i mean i
don't even want them i just love
docusign
see some ladies love their etsy and
pinterest and natasha loves her docusign
pro
we are obsessed with everything hgtv i
mean i like every single show i come
home a night and i'm like
i need a fix and a better be fixer-upper
but house hunters is my favorite
every spin-off every single one but it's
hard
including yours ours are the best but
it's hard to relate to that show
if you live in any big city in america
because every episode is just
unrelatable it's like dan and tasha are
looking for a 25 bedroom house
with 200 bathrooms a pool a tennis court
a tennis court in the pool
and their budget is five dollars i mean
you can't even buy salmon at whole foods
with the amount of money these people
have for a down payment
you can't even buy a mango at trader
joe's
a more realistic thing is dana natasha
are looking for a one-bedroom condo in
west hollywood
they need constant citizen app updates
with murders they need neighbors who
never sleep and spread coven and of
course there's no parking their budget
two million dollars and they miss out
because they were all cash offers
damn you cryptocurrency thank you so
much
[Applause]
oh that's funny dan levy and natasha
legero everyone
wow i love them what a set